[Music]
a seismic shift in climate science
might be heating up new research shows
that sound waves produced by earthquakes
can be used to measure temperatures in
the ocean which traps 90
of the heat earth absorbs from the sun
making long-term changes in ocean warmth
a major factor in how the world might
respond to global warming
for years the mainstay of measuring
ocean temperature has been argo
an array of 4 000 autonomous floats
which drifts the globe
sampling ocean water and measuring its
temperature
yet argo measurements stop at 2 000
meters
the new technique called seismic ocean
thermometry
would be especially useful in detecting
long-term changes in ocean temperatures
deeper than argos reach ocean acoustic
tomography
the basis for the current research was
first tested
nearly 30 years ago the initial studies
created sound waves artificially
basically cranking the volume on giant
underwater speakers
scientists measured the sound's travel
time from the speakers
to receivers thousands of kilometers
away because ocean temperatures affect
the speed of the waves
the researchers could calculate average
temperatures along their paths
but some believe the noise was a threat
to ocean life
and the technique never took off
the new study instead uses a natural
sound source for investigation
earthquakes rumbling beneath the
seafloor off the coast of sumatra
that drum up acoustic waves in the ocean
on the shores of the kagos islands in
the east indian ocean
between 2005 and 2016
seismic station diego garcia recorded
seismic waves
produced by those earthquakes some of
those waves created physical changes
in land and sea as they traveled others
were acoustic waves
or t waves that rippled through the deep
ocean
enroute to delivering valuable data
about ocean temperature
the researchers focused on repeaters
aftershocks with nearly identical
origins
which travel one after the other
by keeping the origin of the waves
relatively constant
repeaters helped the researchers home in
on changes in t-wave travel times
in turn this helped them calculate
changes in ocean temperature
some as subtle as thousands of a degree
celsius
twelve years of data coupled with
mathematical models
pointed to a temperature change of
roughly .04
degrees per decade a trend larger than
those predicted by argo
the finding suggests that seismic ocean
thermometry
is a viable method to measure changes in
ocean temperature
further data from other regions of the
globe and other time frames
would help refine the warming models and
bolster projections
and in future studies the researchers
plan to listen
directly for acoustic waves using a
network of hydrophones
first intended to monitor for nuclear
explosions
acoustic waves set the tone for a deep
dive into our warming oceans
even if they fail to reach 20 000
leagues
under the sea